up first this is kyle dingus ooh
dingus yo what's going on benny has a
problem with you new york
gang gang buzz buzz gang bro i got a
king of the stinger for you guys
bmx riding that handlebar hit her
uh you know i used to bmx when i was
younger me and all my buddies but
i ate [ __ ] too many times and uh i
didn't want to end up like brendan
talking about that cte so i feel you
yeah i got a little video of my younger
brother from back in the day
i just dug it up uh so excuse the poor
quality but i'll show you guys here
i'm just in the field bro
let's just let's go
i was going to jump that hole
should i do it again oh he seems all
right though
when he falls i think he sounds like a
halo 2 character dying
but uh let me know what you guys think
gang gang buzz school video man
yeah bmx riding um could there be a
wider thing in the world
than bmx riding maybe skateboarding hey
yup you're black chappelle yeah and i
skate
yeah there you go brendan you still do
yeah i can still get there once last
time he skated bro
bro last week lil wayne bro how you
doing
i know you're [ __ ] how do you know me
i don't like that you know what
you're doing here i thought he knows me
too dude you should kill him
you could kill him easily probably at
night he could easily do it actually
yeah yeah
you know what i'm going to be bro yeah
dude just poison a [ __ ]
cinnabon you do that
no i'm not shooting you brendan we care
about you too much to do that
poise in his ass what is this guy's
problem again he fell into a hole his
brother fell in the hole
baby jessica or not bmx riding
bmx riding definitely bro it's a huge
sport out there
it's people are flying off the every
everything people can you name a bike
remember huffy yeah alfie was a big one
diamondbacks schwinn
a little bit those are more of the older
16 older crowd i had older friends that
hung out a lot older
but that's not bmx biking that's just
biking well bmx biking is bmx
but they had a certain kind of bike yeah
bmx bike
yeah schwinn really didn't [ __ ] with
that though did they swim was more like
oh i got to get this kid to school or
i'm a parent
yeah my guy there's track
ameritrack yeah cannondale
um oh i know which one there was um
[Music]
red mongoose mongoose was the big one
mongoose mongoose was the big one
and remember you could have uh what uh
what would they put on so you could hang
on the back
eggs hey bro pegs people lost their toes
all the time
dude pegs were dangerous she's getting a
[ __ ] on them and [ __ ] cuz you get back
there with no shoes on sometimes and get
your toe in there and it was a wrap
that was a wrap you bmx or your
rollerblader i was
never a rollerblader dude i would never
i would rather
somebody attack me with a kitchen knife
than rollerblade
i was a we would jump off a ramps until
just like this guy
until somebody got hurt really badly and
then we would keep going though
yeah we didn't do it anymore that guy's
brother almost died they dug a grave for
him and he [ __ ] almost landed
his grave was right there but there was
always i feel like everything was like
that like in neighborhoods you did it
until somebody got hurt so bad that it
was like oh
yeah too much now we can't do it any
better him than me stop doing this yeah
yeah i feel like that's how it always
ended can you name the i'm trying to
think of a famous bmx or
dave big mirror probably the best right
they may or may not know what yeah he
passed away
yeah i think he took his own life yeah
ct
uh i don't know did they they get [ __ ]
up do they oh yeah dude
that's a good question once they start
doing the x game start jumping off
buildings and [ __ ] on these huffies yeah
which you guys started hitting their
heads
isn't there that guy uh tj lavin too he
had like a really bad for
bad fall i think he's dirt bike oh
that's right
but don't they kind of all do everything
no
like tj they all drink red bull i think
they all just
they all drink red bull and monster yeah
yeah they switched to monster about
monster and their ideas monsters those
events that's crazy man
x games is nuts mm-hmm that's crazy
to do all of that and fly around like a
while i know the young one the
skateboard niger houston
houston he's like the michael jordan of
them right the justin bieber
he's he's just like i guess i don't know
he's young like a
this generation is like tony hawk if you
will yeah but he's street and not
verb he's a cool dude yeah
uh yeah i used to do a couple a lot of
different stunts and stuff
probably tricks yeah i was never very
that good at it you really gotta you
weren't no you really gotta go all out
and get injured to get good you know
we always have to correct uh like safety
equipment either like i didn't wear the
elbow pads or the helmet
yeah no i saw somebody wearing a helmet
the other day at a spin class out here
oh my god and i literally almost
[ __ ] drove my car in there and
[ __ ] hit him
uh no we always had like we had this one
kid named larry bro who [ __ ] would do
everything and do it bad and he always
got hurt and he
drew he was biked off the roof remember
that guy like oh this is gonna work you
know
and it just was did he switch his name
to stevo that first tire
and it was always just that first tire
you saw it going you're like
oh man larry's gonna die
it was some dangerous [ __ ] there's
always that one kid who had no [ __ ]
given
yeah didn't care if he got injured he'd
be the first one to do it the ramp
it was this shady cd ramp we'd build or
some [ __ ] like that yeah the worst ramp
and the ramp always like the thing went
down immediately and yeah
yeah it was never good piece of [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] bmx vikings
when you're a kid it's dope though yeah
as a grown man as a
yeah if you started as a kid and you're
a grown man can still do it if you're
making money
if you're making money now if you if
you're that guy on the 16 speed
in the goddamn giant head-to-toe
outfit with you and your boys dude
unless they're paying you quit wearing
that [ __ ]
out the [ __ ] road yeah it drives me
nuts trying to get a contract
you work at chase bank
you have three kids man the contract is
quite wearing that [ __ ] bro yeah
[Music]